I started with nothing my wife and I uh
began this construction company out of
our basement back uh almost 40 years ago
so I've had to work my entire life
nothing's been given to me and and so I
understand the plight of working
Americans and how hard it is to kind of
make things add up at the kitchen table
make sure that you can you know take
your kids on vacation make sure you can
still put groceries on the table and you
can pay the heating bill pay the rent
Bill and so it's just Americans are
feeling stretched right now and very
insecure and and so that's why my
candidacy makes a lot of sense for
Colorado we need some new policies in
place that'll that'll help working
Americans and that's why I'm running
this race I'm a fourth generation
Colorado and I grew up here Southeast
Denver I was there before there were a
lot of paved roads mostly field and
Cattle
my dad and mom were loving I mean I was
adopted uh they uh they took us in and
uh they gave us a great childhood uh
gave us a great upbringing my dad truly
believed that education was the was the
key uh to success for people and so he
ingrained that in us but he also
ingrained in US respect for Law and
Order
as a cop son you're constantly worried
about embarrassing your dad because you
know if you do something out of line the
Wrath will follow you
I think the other thing that growing up
in a cop's house really gives you a
sense of is how dangerous that job is I
can remember going to sleep at as a five
or six year old kid and wondering you
know whether or not your dad was going
to come home from his job
I transferred from a from a public
school to an all boys Catholic school I
met my wife about that time chased her
on up to Colorado State University
when I got out of high school I took
three years off I started an
apprenticeship right out of my junior
year in in high school I was a uni
carpet for three or four years I've got
most of my construction management
degree I got an academic scholarship I
made the Dean's List Straight A's first
semester and after that they paid paid
part of my school
I dropped out because I didn't want to
pay for another semester of tuition I
needed to get to work
just decided that you know what I'll get
to it later later never happened the
business started and uh you know when
you're working 80 hundred hours a week
on your business you don't have time uh
to do a paper or those kind of things
most of us that are entrepreneurs have
started our own businesses we get up
four o'clock in the morning I would do
uh payroll make sure I keep track of the
time for the guys I would pay any bills
that I needed before I left the house I
was usually on the job site by 6 a.m and
I was there till seven at night and then
when I get home maybe I have time for a
little bit of dinner say hi to my wife
hit the hay by 9 30 10 and get up and do
it again
I can remember several Sundays that I
worked on changing an engine out of a of
a loader or out of a truck because we
couldn't afford mechanics my my partner
and I did it ourselves
you got to be tough enough to weather
the storm and we've been through three
recessions so I've seen all sides of the
construction industry we built a great
group of people I'm very proud of the
work that we've done across the state
and I'm very proud of the proud of the
team that I've been able to put together
you just get up every morning and do the
best you can and that's how you're
successful
I know how it is to negotiate with
customers both Democrats and Republicans
to have a great outcome for projects
that we've been in charge of and those
that skill set makes me uniquely
qualified to do the job of a U.S senator
that gives me a significant advantage
over a senator Bennett